so a whole bunch of very incriminating
emails have leaked which show that the
White House and really everybody around
president Donald Trump knew all along
that the goal of withholding aid from
Ukraine was to get them to do the thing
he wants to do to get him that
deliverable which is these public
announcements about investigations into
Joe and hunter Biden for the purposes of
smearing the Biden's and helping Donald
Trump in 2020 and it's almost
anticlimactic to report this to you
because anybody who had been following
the story with with some level of
closeness and has been following Donald
Trump for three years or longer would
understand that that's exactly how it
went down and these are what can
potentially be called smoking gun emails
with regards to what took place The
Washington Post is now reporting that
hundreds of documents have turned up
which show that after the fact after the
decision was made to withhold the aid
from Ukraine everybody at the White
House was scrambling trying to come up
with some explanation a false
explanation of course an explanation
other than the real one for why the
hundreds of millions of dollars in aid
were being withheld from Ukraine we of
course know that it was because Donald
Trump wanted to use that money as a way
to get Ukraine to smear Joe Biden so
let's back it up just a little bit here
one of the defenses that we're hearing
from trumpets is listen everything's
fine because eventually Trump gave
Ukraine the aid now at face value this
is a worthless defense because it
implies that trying to commit a crime
isn't a problem as long as you fail to
commit it which is ridiculous apply that
same logic to any other situation it
doesn't make any sense but even more
absurd is that the aid was released when
Adam Schiff sent a letter saying hey a
whistleblower is telling us that you're
holding the aide hostage for a smear
campaign against Joe Biden and then lo
and behold the aide is then released to
Ukraine and that is that action is now
pointed to to say hey
you we eventually gave him the AIDS so
there's nothing to see here
but we now have the emails and they
expose that not only did people like
Donald Trump's chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney know exactly what Donald Trump
was doing they were worried it was not
even legal back in August remember that
the infamous phone call between Donald
Trump and President szalinski of Ukraine
was on July 25 very close to August in
August Mulvaney knowing that the aid had
been withheld asked the director of the
Office of Management and Budget OMB for
an update on the legal rationale for
withholding aid and how much longer can
we withhold the aid because Mulvaney
knew why it was being withheld and he
suspected he feared that it could be
legally problematic emails were then
turned up between OMB and the State
Department the State Department
officials corresponding about this with
OMB also we're saying well hold on a
second withholding this might be against
the law the funds are congressionally
approved and now they are being withheld
for what they of course suspected were
political reasons what is Trump doing
wire how long can this go on is this
even legal so ultimately we have the
same story from all fronts the
whistleblower says Trump is holding up a
door was holding up aid to get Ukraine
to smear Biden it was a form of bribery
extortion Trump then goes on Fox &
Friends and in not so many words says
yeah I told them to investigate
corruption which is of course code for
smear the Biden's publicly and why
should we give them money anyway
linking the investigation and the money
publicly for the first time as we told
you yesterday without even realizing it
that story overnight 350,000 views on
YouTube generating a lot of interest as
it should then we heard from the
impeachment witnesses last week in the
week before Gordon sunland's saying
there was a quid pro quo and I suspect
that there were actually two quid pro
quos quid pro quo more witnesses last
week adding fuel to the fire everybody
knew this maybe as I read on Twitter
this may be the most meticulously and
Sibley documented presidential bribery
extortion scheme that we have ever seen
and yet as we get to the other end of it
in all likelihood and it pains me to say
this and I know people get mad because
they say I'm conceding I'm not conceding
I'm simply analyzing that in all
likelihood the Republicans in the Senate
are going to let Donald Trump remain in
office and will cheer at least publicly
behind closed doors who knows they will
at least publicly cheer the reelection
of Donald Trump if if if it indeed
happens despite everything that everyday
we are learning every day we learn
enough that by itself what we learn on
that day would be a non-stop scandal
under Barack Obama and yet Republicans
and mostly Fox News and other right-wing
media defend the president make excuses
stand aside they are all enablers for
what is going on here one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you $5.00 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a life saver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
right
denne private by not telling companies
who you are you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman